(acclamation de la foule)
- Le président Jair Bolsonaro
aime la moto, et c'est en convoi
de motos et à Sao Paulo qu'il a
choisi de terminer sa campagne
pour le premier tour.
La propagande politiqu
est terminée depuis hier soir,
mais certaines activités
sont encore permises.
- Primero turno! Primero turno!
- "Bolsonaro au premier tour",
crient ses partisans.
C'est peu probable, selon
les sondages, mais ses partisans
y croient. Sa base électorale
est de 30 à 36 %, mais elle est
solide, voire fanatique.
(cris en choeur)
Cette base ne bougera pas,
mais le reste de la population
brésilienne va voter demain
sur la base du bilan de
quatre ans de Jair Bolsonaro,
un bilan que plusieurs analystes
jugent désastreux à de nombreux
points de vue.
RICARDO HENRIQUES,
analyste politique
- Du point de vue
de l'environnement,
du point de vue de l'éducation,
du point de vue de la culture,
du point de vue de la science,
vraiment un désastre.
Delilililitique publique
vers les plus vulnérables,
ils sont carrément détruits.
(acclamation de la foule)
- En face, l'ex-président Lula,
Luiz Inácio da Silva. Le bilan
de ses deux mandats est mitigé,
les scandales de corruption qui
ont entaché les gouvernements
du d d d des travailleurs ont
laissé des traces. Alors, si
les Brésiliens le choisissent,
c'est qu'ils le considèrerontmm.
L'ex-président Lula s'est engagé
à reconstruire ces institutions
et nvnvnvnvestir dans
les programmes sociaux
nécessaires pour sortir le tiers
des Brésiliens de la pauvreté
l l l laquelle ils vivent.
C'est ce qu'il avait réussi de
mieux dans son premier mandat.
Il devra aussi apaiserlalalala d
le discours de Jair Bolsonaro.
- Les milices annoncent une
lutte contre les institutions
et contre l'"establishment",
mais, en même temps, disent
que la façon de faire ça,
c'est armer les gens et créer
des réseaux qui sont, je crois,
en limite, criminels. Ils sont
capables de substituer l'État.
- Un lendemain d'élection
sans violence, c'est ce que
tout le monde ose espérer.
Mais quand? Au premier ou dans
un deuxième tour le 30 octobre?
Les deux derniers sondages qui
viennent tout juste de tomber
donnent encore une légère avance
à Lula avec 50 et 51 %,
mais ça ne lui garantit pas
forcément une victoire
dès le premier tour.
Jean-Michel Leprince,
Radio-Canada, Rio de Janeir